so how much are you looking forward to
going into space then
very much yeah thank you it's a it's a
really exciting time and I think
everybody who's been selected this round
is really looking forward to everything
that Issa has planned over the next
decade or two absolutely
so what are the plans do you know yet
well we're pretty much still involved
with the International Space Station the
ISS and that will be continuing until
2030 and then looking to the longer term
you may be aware you spoke about um
being the anniversary of the Apollo 17
Mission but actually our first attempt
to go back to the Moon is now on its way
back home having successfully done a
couple of flybys of the Moon that's the
Artemis One mission and from Artemis one
which is an unmanned crew an unmanned
the Expedition will be starting to do
crude missions and getting both um women
Americans Europeans lots more people on
the moon to do science
you could be the first person born on
the island of Ireland to go to space
um that would be a historic moment
wouldn't it how does that make you feel
yes that's right yeah really proud and
really proud in so many senses to be to
be expanding that group of people who
are able to go into the space obviously
pushing for diversity and encouraging
stem has been a really big a really big
thing the selection around and I'm
really proud to be to be a woman to be
born on the island of Ireland to be to
be part of this process yeah
um today marking the uh beginning of the
50th Anniversary can't believe it of
Apollo 17 which was I think the final
mission wasn't it um and NASA's Apollo
program
um
what what did you know about that I mean
I'm sure you weren't even born when that
happened
um but when you look back at uh this
sort of well this is actually the first
mission wasn't it this is not uh Apollo
17 but when you look back at man on the
moon
um do you want to be the first woman on
the moon
okay
well of course I think we all we all
dream of going to the Moon I'm sure that
the first woman on the moon will be an
American woman that will be um a part of
a NASA Mission as part of Artemis 3
um or join NASA Esa Mission but it will
be an American woman and that's going to
be fantastic to see the first woman on
the moon and I'll be very proud if I
have an opportunity to go to the moon
and be the first European or the second
European or as long as we're doing
everything we can out there learning as
much as we can that's going to be great
fantastic
um why has it taken 50 years for us to
think about putting a human back on the
moon
it's it's a good question and actually
things have changed a lot in the last 50
years of course Apollo has really set
the scene for everything we want to do
now in terms of those initial
investigations and actually we've come
to the stage where we're still analyzing
rocks or samples brought back from the
Apollo missions but with brand new
technology technology that didn't exist
50 years ago so now we know that for
example there are volatiles there is
thought to be frozen water in the South
Pole of the Moon in these permanently
shadowed regions and now we have the
technology and the knowledge to go to a
different part of the Moon and really
start to explore something different
um was it programs like Apollo that
attracted you to want to go into space
or is it something that you've always
wanted to do since you were a little
girl
Apollo has been absolutely inspirational
I think there's a number of factors that
really attracted me into the space
sector and particularly to becoming an
astronaut my current job as an
astrophysicist does focus on space but
it's a completely different space
science to what we will do as astronauts
but of course
um everything that happened 50 years ago
is is completely completely
inspirational and I hope that we can do
that now for the next Generations in the
next few years fantastic good to talk to
you thank you
thank you very much